you tell a Christmas story in the book
are you spoiling that chapter it's
called die hard all right well I'm not
gonna spoil it it's really good I I was
very proud of that chapter why
I think it's just because the ending
that's a Christmas story is just like I
know everyone reading it's gonna go
Google it be like he can't he can't be
real but it was real he said it was on
Christmas yes sure
um I mean that this has to do with the
bigger picture we don't have to uh do
the big reveal but the bigger picture of
there there was an iron curtain and it
was coming down in complex ways
how would you define the Iron Curtain
there's a there's just a set of
ideologies a set of countries United by
an ideology and a set of countries you
know by a different ideology
and um
there's a curtain that divided them and
it eventually came down so how how would
you describe how it came down
it came I I hate that I can never
remember ever ever remember if this was
Hemingway
uh no it was Hemingway it was Mark Twain
no it came down two ways gradually then
suddenly
um
the thing with the Iron Curtain and the
Warsaw Pact these were a bunch of
nations with you know run under
communism but they were all almost all
under the sway of Moscow
so if they were going to make big
changes Moscow had to uh prove it
um it was in 19 in the early in the 50s
we're in Hungary
uh decided to Rebel or not Rebel
liberalize and they even were thinking
of leaving the Warsaw Pact and the
Russians send in the tanks and you had
the development of what was called the
bridge nav Doctrine which was the idea
that it is the duty of all the Warsaw
Pac Nations if another country tries to
and this was also 68 in the Prague
spring in Czechoslovakia if a nation
wants to leave uh socialism it is in
common of those socialist Nations to to
do whatever is necessary to make sure
there isn't a counter Revolution so they
were
very much under moscow's thumb
um and one of the big ways it changed
was one man and that was Mikhail
Gorbachev and he was the first Russian
leader to be born after the October
Revolution he grew up and his
grandfather was arrested for being a
trotskyite and the other one you know
was arrested for this or that he saw his
village starve as a result of Stalin so
even though he was a very committed
communist he also was very an
increasingly skeptical of
authoritarianism
and you know in Poland for example you
had the solidarity movement
um and this is a labor union movement
and the government didn't know what to
do they were getting a lot of support
from the peoples they had strikes that
um the dance Shipyard was was when them
started and basically Moscow told them
either you crack down or we're cracking
down on you
and they're like all right and they
declared martial law and they you know
arrested leaders put them away but then
when Gorbachev you know was in charge
there wasn't a gun to their back and it
was the Communist leaders themselves who
were like you know what there's this
really funny moment where
um like for let's say is meeting with
Margaret Thatcher and she's he's telling
her what solidarity the movement wants
and she had been meeting with the Polish
government as well and she's like look
like
tell them like what because they they
had you tried they they wanted the
government wanted her to tell them that
we want to negotiate and work things out
she goes all right tell the government
what it is that you're asking for and he
just points to the ceiling she goes he's
like oh yeah our meetings are bugged
anyway
um but they then had the freedom because
they knew that Gorbachev wasn't forcing
them to drive solidarity underground so
they had the idea of like let's work
together with these people and as a
result of this you know Poland
liberalized and freed itself uh um
fairly easily and with a minimum of
Bloodshed in 89 and it there was this
whole argument for the Vietnam war with
something called Domino Theory which is
if you lose Vietnam then you're going to
lose Laos then you lose Cambodia one by
one the countries are going to turn
Communists like dominoes but people
didn't realize the reverse was true
because after Poland liberalized then
you have you know a Hungary then you
have you know Czechoslovakia then you
know that you had East Germany and the
fall of the Berlin Wall so it's a great
thing because as this is happening
the people are looking around and
they're like wait like that's that's
that's it like this has got to be a
trick and it wasn't a trick so one of my
favorite books which was a big
inspiration for this one was by my
favorite historian I apologize to Victor
Patricia David Patricia and Arthur
Herman my second and third uh they're
tied but uh Victor Sebastian wrote a
book called Revolution uh 1989 and he
just talked about that year and how all
these countries one after another
liberalized and it's just such a beaut
and none of them thought this was
possible my one my favorite favorite
moments in this book
is helmet Cole who was the head of West
Germany is in Warsaw with like valessa
uh discussing the Berlin wall and like
Willis is like I don't think it's gonna
be around for like another you know few
years and at home Nicole laughs in his
face and he goes look you're young this
isn't how things work like this is gonna
take some doing it fell the next day and
Hell Nicole literally says I'm at the
wrong party and he got in a plane and
got out of Warsaw so there are why this
book has a broader message than the
actual stories of these incidents is
that as these wonderful things are
happening the universal consensus at the
time is it's never gonna happen or if it
does have gonna happen it's gonna happen
only through an enormous amount of
Carnage and blood and when it doesn't
then everyone's like oh it was
inevitable you didn't say it was
inevitable at the time you only said it
was inevitable after the fact and the
other thing that I was really brought me
a lot of joy is there's so many moments
of men with guns
saying we're not shooting anyone because
they wanted several tianmen squares they
wanted it in you know East Berlin they
wanted it in Romania they wanted in
Moscow and these strong tough trained
men with guns were like no we're not
shooting the civilians and then
everything else was history
yeah just as surprising as the mass
violence committed by uh like police and
the Army on its own citizenry equally
surprising is when they choose not to
yeah somehow
yeah
and what is that what uh how do you
explain uh 1989 how do you explain this
progress
that happened so suddenly
how do you explain that in the at the
beginning of the 20th century
so much Revolution happened that created
communism
and how do you explain then the collapse
of that across So Many Nations at the
same time I think a large part of it had
to do with the closer
um interconnections between people like
Gorbachev and Thatcher and Gorbachev and
Reagan because both of them visited red
square and you know in the years before
these are these are enemies you know
they want to invade they want to kill us
the Americans thought this about the
Russians the Russians thought this about
the Americans obviously not so much the
British and
they got on really well uh when
Gorbachev came to Checkers which is the
prime minister's uh Countryside estate
uh Thatcher sat him down and she's
lecturing him about human rights and
she's lecturing about economics and
she's lecturing about this and that and
then she's lecturing him about why he's
in eating while he's yelling at her and
he goes Mrs Thatcher like I know you
have a lot of strong opinions
I do too I haven't been sent here to
recruit you the Communist party and she
just started laughing but right away
there was such a sense in the air of we
can do better we're spending all this
money on missiles we're spending all
this money on the military it's
expensive and for what uh we don't have
to be looking at each other as enemies
we can try to work together to kind of
at the very least lower the the the the
volume and the the heat how much credit
do you give to Gorbachev the man so
meaning how much power does a single
individual have I I could not give him
more credit uh I had a tweet last year
where I said who do you think is the
greatest person alive right now and my
answer by far would be Gorbachev then he
died I don't know who it is right now
but it's just funny because Gorbachev
also had a tweet
but it was it was like and he said oh
sure
um that would be a good now I wish I
interviewed Gorbachev and asked him the
the famous question of what would you
like best about Michael Mouse